les acérocaldens sont ce qu'on appelle
des chrétiens d'Orient ce sont ceux qui
parlent la langue du Christ qui parle
l'araméen et quand les Ottomans et les
Kurdes ont massacré en 1915 ils n'ont
pas distingué entre les Arméniens les
Grecs vont-ils les caldéens les yésidis
également c'est plus de la moitié de la
population chrétienne qui a été
massacrée passée par le fil de l'épée
sur sa terre sur son propre sol puisque
bien évidemment il précédait les
Ottomans et l'islam et ils étaient
massacrés dans une volonté d'épuration
ethnique culturelle cultuelles ils
appellent ce grand massacre safiot passé
par l'épée qui est un nom araméen et
d'ailleurs ce mot a une importance
particulière puisque aujourd'hui
Erdogan appelle les Arméniens et les
chrétiens d'Orient les résidus de l'épée
ce qui est un une allusion très nette
au massacre de 1915 qui ne reconnaît pas
je me suis dit qu'il était important de
se dire que dans l'histoire c'est pas
une opération isolée de massacre de
masse mais c'était bien la continuation
d'une volonté d'éradication
de ces personnes sur leur terre
ancestrales pour effacer les traces et
que aujourd'hui on connaît
malheureusement par sa gravité son
ampleur et et ça poursuit puisque
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe au Karaba
c'est la poursuite de la volonté
génocidaire des azerbaïdjanais et des
Turcs envers les Arméniens et on voit
que bien évidemment en Irak et en Syrie
il s'agit de la même chose donc c'est la
poursuite du génocide de 1915 qui
lui-même était la poursuite de plusieurs
génocides puisqu'il faut se rappeler
qu'à cette époque sous l'Empire ottoman
tout ce qui n'était pas musulman tout ce
qui n'était pas lié à l'Empire ottoman
directement et notamment les chrétiens
vivaient étaient des sous citoyens
puisqu'il vivait sous le régime de la
diminution ils étaient obligés de
particulier et il n'avait pas les mêmes
droits que les autres et bien ça
commençait comme ça puis après ça a été
leur éradication et que dans des terres
où il n'y a plus de pluralité ou on
efface la mémoire ou on efface
l'histoire ou ceux qui parlent la langue
du Christ est bien son chasser de
l'endroit où
ils sont là depuis plus de 2000 ans et
bien c'est notre devoir de se souvenir
non pas simplement pour mettre un
linceul mais aussi pour éviter que les
choses ne se reproduisent aujourd'hui